ja das fragen lotto wir haben wieder
lange gebrütet wie können wir diesen man
provozieren oder
vollkommen unterwürfige harmlose fragen
stellen aber das ist jetzt an provokante
sehr schöne frage was verstehen sie
unter einem emanzipatorischen
fortsetzungsroman für frauen meinen
jetzt wenn ich
also ganz eindeutig mein roman ist ein
emanzipatorischer fortsetzungsroman für
frauen und um ganz genau zu sein ein
katholischer emanzipations roman für
frauen wird sich ja eher an wie ein
werbespruch um möglichst eine große
zielgruppe zu erreichen naja grenzen
sich rachel einige aus die protestanten
werden sagen warum solchen katholischen
emanzipations roman lesen wollen die
katholiken selber lesen denn er ist
schon sehr bewusst genauso eng gefasst
das ist ja auch
das buch ist ja
erheiternd aber es ist nicht unbedingt
reine comedy licht
war das etwas was auch in der
geschlummert hatte er hat nur wollte
etwas ernsthafteres ja weil ich finde
man kann unter dem label comedy auch
eine menge ernsthaftigkeit verkaufen
wenn sie so unterschwellig mit verkaufen
wird und ich finde es geht ja hier
tatsächlich um liebe es geht auch um die
rolle der frau in der katholischen
kirche und es geht vor allen dingen
darum dass männer die nicht brachial
komisch unterwegs sind und ständig den
helden spielen auch helden sein können
und mein held ist ja am ende ein echter
held und einer wo man sagen kann so ein
hätte ich auch gern immer arzt mal also
nicht wie die frauen von daher schon
eine menge darunter und deshalb trifft
dieser titel also auch was für verkannte
männer dieses buch das ist für alle also
gerne auch mal männer wohl ist durch
mehr frauen die das buch lesen weiß gar
nicht warum
sind sie ein landei ja ich war es nicht
immer von geburt an ich bin ja bochumer
also klassische metropole mittlerweile
überzeugt ausland teil aber das ist ja
wirklich so ist sehr provinziell
da kennt man den bäcker beim namen und
wie geht's denn er gantenberg da ist gut
geschlafen genau schlecht geträumt ich
und das schöne ist ich bin in soest mit
abstand der erfolgreichste
schriftsteller das ist etwas was ich
woanders nicht wieder hier in köln ist
einer von ganz viel ist noch den
erfolgreichsten sänger ein so sagen das
auch noch es gibt den erfolgreichsten
musikmanager dieter gorny
in ordnung sind ja ja und ja also diese
stadt bringt schon menschen hervor als
drehbuchautor waren sie im hintergrund
haben sie jetzt ein buch geschrieben
damit sie sich auch mal in den
vordergrund spielen können als
drehbuchautor welcher liga eingeladen
worden aber als buchautor als romanautor
klar ja ich hab's geschrieben um auch
mal hier zu sein schön ja müsste noch
eine provokante
westen also die provokanten wie finde
ich geholt
die sind auch schwer ich bin die auch
weil das es so wie ein fan wänden
fenstern vor einem steht sie sind so
toll so der frage habe ich gerechnet all
ihre preise bekam sie für comedy formate
haben sie kein talent für seriöse doch
erstens ist auch comedy series
zweibeiner immer schon ja also gute
comedy sehr seriös weil es gibt ja auch
gutes kabarett und kabarettist auch
seriös und die menschen haben in der
regel auch schon mal irgendein füllten
teil einer zeitung gelesen und das tue
ich ich sogar aber um das auch wieder
jedem zu beweisen ich habe einen krimi
geschrieben des zdf mit senta berger
komplett frei ohne jeden humor brutal
ernst seriös wie kommt man an so einen
auftrag als comedy autor ja weil da sind
menschen die haben sonst nur com/de ich
kann etwas anderes sind beweist doch mal
so ungefährlich fast nicht ungefähr so
und ja hat funktioniert und kommt bald
im zdf waren ich hoffe ich hoffe noch im
herbst 2009 will ich haben dann erst im
frühjahr 2
der reifegrad
hätten sie mit dem großen erfolg ihres
buches gerechnet ganz ehrlich gesagt ja
ich bin echt davon ausgegangen dass es
sich einigermaßen verkauft alles andere
hätte mich dazu gebracht zu gucken wie
hoch die rheinbrücke wobei ist so ein
buch wie in risiko dass neue erscheinung
jetzt gibt es neue sacher grund eine art
mängelexemplar geschrieben ich meine das
ist so ein titel da würde ich jetzt
nicht als erstes sagen das muss ich
haben weil das ist ein fachbegriff er
sein glück gehabt wird ja auch
grabbeltisch drauf stehen können oder
ich fand das war noch ok aber glücklich
und neuerscheinungen
wessen idee war das denn der verlag der
verlag der verlag der heute endlich mal
eine neue seite holte eine
neuerscheinung haben
so sie waren noch nie fest angestellt
woher kommt das selbstvertrauen dass es
immer weitergeht
hatte ich ja nicht immer dieses
selbstvertrauen mittlerweile glaube ich
dass ich weiß was ich kann und gehe
davon aus dass das was ich kann ich auch
noch in zukunft kann daher kommt das
selbstvertrauen ich glaube der erste
echte flop wird dazu führen dass ich mir
über diese frage ernsthaft gedanken
machen als heute
900 nicht der erste flug pro
903 ein arthouse film so verkaufen
mittlerweile und von arthouse filme
250.000 zuschauer bomba war eigentlich
war es eine große deutsche komödie und
sollte wahrscheinlich millionen in die
kinos locken eigentlich genau so dass
zwar die absicht aber wir haben ihn
komplett versenkt und bei dem titel auch
damals zu bleiben war schuld nicht das
buch
da gab es ganz ganz viel schuld habe
aber die werde ich hier öffentlich nicht
mehr hinten richten wollen schaden ja
noch werden was gewesen das wäre echt
gewesen aber ich hab dann parallel zu
diesem flop auch schon mal ein buch
geschrieben dass man ganz gut sind sie
auch privat ein lustiger typ die einen
sagen so die anderen so ich glaube ich
bin in der mitte irgendwie semi lustig
okay sind westfalen waren symbole
westfalen bin ich eine granate also
wirklich eine echte granate rheine noch
nach ja ich würde sagen das ist die
beste aller fragen oder ist die verpasst
möchte nicht wie noch zielsicher
erinnern
wann war ihnen klar dass sie ihr
schreibt dass ihr schreibtalent so groß
ist dass sie davon leben können
gute frage das war mir klar als ich das
erste mal eine serie verkauft habe weil
dann gibt es schon so viel geld dass man
sagen kann dann müssen die kinder nicht
mit kurzen hosen mit silber rumrennen da
war mir das klar dass ich davon leben
kann da der verkauf ist so bleibt das
sollten wir auch weiterhin viel erfolg
dabei michael schönen vielfach